yeah hello and welcome to this
broadcast let's start the actual
transmission
here okay now I should be on yeah good
evening to all of you I mean evening in
Europe not sure where you are watching
from yeah I hope that this broadcast is
working fine from a technical point of
view um I didn't um change anything
substantial but I did alter my sound
settings a little bit so I think that my
audio quality should
increase at least that's what I believe
so it would be great if you can give me
some information if um I'm really um
yeah I'm really loud and clear this so
to
say okay how are you guys
any message here in
chat
yeah hello I think there are some some
people around who are not there um have
not been here before so welcome to all
the all the new guys yeah sounds fine
that's good so with everything's fine uh
I might as well start okay let me have a
look here I want to check if there's
something great to kibitz on it could be
it could be that we have some
interesting games to kbits not at the
moment it seems H um morovich was
playing quite a lot earlier this um this
um evening so this is something to watch
out for but at the moment there's
nothing too
great
um so I'm going to play games myself a
little bit like two or three and then
I'm always having an an eye um on the
things that happen here in the in the
ICC Community if some nice games are
being started oky doie I'm going to
start a five minute game and see what
happens I haven't played a game of chess
today I played one game to test out my
my technical setup but I kind of feel
Rusty yeah kind of feel
Rusty what do we get yes wow this I
cannot
pronounce SC Scot age lost wow that's
weird okay I'm going to go D4 as I
normally do and see okay guy wants to
bought yeah okay I'm going to comply to
that maybe he started the game and um
then something happened okay new game
Herman Steiner I usually compain apply
to to aborts I mean people normally have
a reason for requesting
it okay he said he has a bad lag and um
he had yeah okay that's okay so um Four
Knights here with black for Knight
Scotch oh the Belgrade Gambit yeah
that's not a super great opening but
it's um definitely not so bad I recently
lost against thisy gu he got me with a
with a funny tactical Motif with a cross
pin something that you don't see that
often um yeah how do I play here yeah I
forgot I forgot the theory H yeah I'm
just going to develop here with castles
I will I look at the chat definitely but
um I'm focusing a bit on on the game
when I'm
playing um so any any games said do you
think you work harder than average IMS
um I don't know
uh yeah I mean I'm I'm I'm mostly
focusing on uh on my my teaching
Endeavors and um it's not like I'm
focusing so much on my own play I like
to play better of course but um I don't
really um have that much time to improve
my own game yeah
here here I'm I'm a pawn up in this
Belgrade Gambit but white definitely has
a good
development yeah and I think why not C6
where okay where goes C6 he's got this
somewhat annoying pin set up and I don't
want to play
G5 h n okay well
can also Play Bishop E7 but okay D6
should be fine I want to get the bishop
out um Queen D2 I don't know what he's
what he intends to do here I don't
really understand that okay I get I go
Bishop G4 trying to trade over the
Knight oh that's it okay but I can take
now right right that shouldn't be
bad yeah I'm in this spin on
F6 I'm in this pin on
F6 all it's not so that's not so easy to
play I Can Go rookie eight uh rookie one
yeah the penis is an
annoying is an annoying feature of this
position I
wonder I wonder if I should play G5 or
not I think it's hard not
to
yeah guys I will look at the questions
um after the game is finished and and go
through them I think it's um it's um a
fair thing to do I really want to answer
them but it is not so easy during the
game
um yeah Queen D7 maybe it's got Bishop
F5
coming I don't know that's not easy to
play here this position this G5 move
weakened um quite a lot
yeah I thought that when he's going to
uh F5 I can actually move the queen away
but he can go Bishop D3 at least for a
repetition probably has other things in
mind
but G5 is
unprotected Bishop D3
however it's at least equal for white I
don't really see how to avoid the
repetition I think I probably can be
glad if it happens
someone asked about the Silman book I
never um looked at any book of Jeremy
Silman
nothing uh yeah not not that I don't
like him or anything I simply have no
experience with those books they are
mostly um aimed at a somewhat
um um yeah weaker audience than than I
am or or was in the past and this is why
I never looked at them for myself yeah
as a training tool maybe I can use the
books um now that I'm a teacher
mostly yeah it's very difficult I I
don't think I can avoid the repetition
here okay after Bishop F5 I could go to
the8 yeah simply back to
the8 trying to play for a win which is a
bit risky but he has spent some time now
so maybe um I can I can do that and yeah
I'm preparing Rook H5
here um
okay maybe I can go I wants to go to G3
or
maybe
maybe but F4 I mean then just D3 yeah so
it's not really a problem I can even try
for queen
h8
okay maybe yeah maybe just back I don't
know maybe just back G4 doesn't look
like a move that should help him that
much but I'm still behind on the clock a
bit he can he cannot attack G5 at the
moment which is which is
nice I'm going to try to play Rook e
eight for some
trades oh I didn't see that one
coming that's not good just ATT teack C7
here Bishop
E6 Bishop E6 Rook f8 that looks kind of
risky but I avoided the draw
earlier so this is what you get when you
want to play for a win in a position
that is not really
Justified Queen G5 Rook G6 looks very
shaky but maybe it's it's possible here
then G5 yeah it's got G5
coming maybe I have to go back here
maybe still G5 yeah Rook
G5 I can take on E6 but he's got Rook H1
coming that's not
good really
not yeah I should have just gone for
this draw it seems this uh didn't end
very well
39 seconds
H and the bishop F5 is very
easy yeah I don't know maybe it wasn't
that bad to avoid the draw but um I
couldn't really handle the position very
much okay Wow Let's resign
that um so there a couple of question
question uh will you play longer time
controls live no not here that's a bit
too long 15
minutes
um what is better close Spanish or open
it's both interesting
really let's have a look some other
older some questions before that that I
that I overlooked yeah if there's
something really important just get this
question in again it's a little bit
difficult to
um do it all of the
time oh well I really know why some
people keep spam spamming this uh this
chat yeah it's uh nothing better to do
than uh spaming uh spamming a chat a
chess chat is quite it's quite
embarrassing okay so a new
game and um let's see what I got I don't
get a game why is
that there actually some interesting
games to watch so after I've played
myself I really really want to get a
um get a win in how do I to get P cpri
okay peted corpit that's probably the
wrong way to pronounce
it G and Rebecca
okay so I got
a can you play the modern defense yes I
can can you recommend a side server for
longer time control games yeah I think I
see is quite good for that I don't think
there is um a server that's um any
better for for longer time
controls okay we got a a BOGO here BOGO
type against
um um against um G3 against the Catalin
here I'm playing with a quick C5 um
getting good development and um I think
this is a very decent line for black
let's see Knight
C6 I can also take on
C4 okay going to
take have I ever played in the Belgian
inter unb yeah probably
yes I've played in Belgium for so long I
probably have played an adverb um at
some
point how often do you take extended
breaks from chess to be honest really
never I did play relatively little chess
some years ago when I played lots of
Poker but this is gone and nowadays I
really never take any
breaks it's kind of um yeah it's kind of
crazy so I'm a I'm a pawn up here that's
the good news shall I really take there
it helps him a little bit with this
development yeah probably Queen C7
intending Rook
d8 yeah yeah that's that's
better and let's see now I can cover
this Pawn with Bishop to E6 yeah I
will why not Knight G5 there is um
Knight D4
coming okay so I'm a pawn up that's
good he might take on F6 and spoil my
Pawn structure a bit but that's not that
bad I'm actually ready now to play B5
now that I have moved the Rook away from
A8 so I'm pretty much a pawn up for not
much at least that's what I believe but
he might get some compensation when I do
something stupid it it can happen it's
not so easy to
play besides tactic problems can you
recommend a good way to improve border
awareness
um I don't know I mean practicing
tactics um is a good way to increase
that lower your blunder rate I also feel
that it is um a good idea to study lots
of games um from the openings um and
structures that you play I'm Not uh
saying that you should learn opening
moves by heart but look at um the
structures that arise it will give you
give you better feel what is looking
normal what is a good move in in the
type of position what sort of belongs
there and if you improve your feeling on
on that part of the game you will make
less and less moves that simply don't
fit it is uh I think
helping um can you recommend a good book
or dvd against the Spanish yeah black
black book
um there are some it's an interesting
book is this book by Ian sof on all the
sidelines that is uh pretty good but
it's a couple of years old there is
nothing great on the closed Spanish
really which is a shame as it is such a
such a um such a versatile opening I'm
going to try something here I think this
is quite good
because here he cannot take on H6 after
King G7 I'm trapping his
Knight and the light squares now look
awfully weak so I hope um I'm really I
really have a big Advantage here I'm
getting Queen D2 in as he has to go back
now so Queen D2 and this is a really
great position my Bishop is uh far
superior to his Knight so I hope I'm
getting a win in
here
yeah Bishop F5 would be great
right I wonder I can probably just go
here intending Bishop to
E4 um I have never played against Zava
but I like his chess he's really a very
interesting
player it's um very it's always
interesting to watch it's um yeah he's
like I mean it's the same for this
Hungarian player Richard raport he
always has interesting games it's simply
not happening that he's playing
something
boring so
um
um uh any any things no there's many
there's lots of spam going on but I
won't answer to that I really don't mind
a little bit of spam as long it's funny
but uh it should be at least a little
bit
creative stuff like that's so gay that's
not really
creative um do you think you are still
improving your chess well I'm not learn
I'm not really working on my chess but I
do lots of Chess of course while I mean
I'm I'm what I'm teaching and um it
helps to to stay focused and and be keep
in shape
um the the modern defense I think I
don't know if I played OAS against my
latest after the latest games are
uploaded I play all the time so probably
yes I have never played The Budapest
Gambit um in in a serious game and uh
even in Blitz it's been very rare yeah
this is a funny position now why is
almost stalemated here it's very hard
for him to move anything I will just go
with with a king Invasion
now yeah he really cannot move
anything going to C5 and A4 probably
there's something quicker but he has no
moves there
simply if he goes to H4 yeah um I mean I
can put Bishop I can put the bishop to
F3 at at any given point and then Rook
D1 yeah in fact I could have done that
earlier even but this is possible here
for Rook
D1 what line um do I recommend against
the queen C2 nimzo well um now he
resigned that's good yeah Rook D1 wasn't
um wasn't um yeah he cannot prevent it
um Queen C2 yeah Queen C2 is the main
line against the nimzo I'm I'm
recommending the move Knight C6 in my
upcoming book The Zurich variation there
are some good lines though I think
castles is also very good intending A3
and then D5 with what kumnick
plays
um uh uh do I learn from my students
yeah sure I mean it is very interesting
to go over um training positions with
students of all levels because it's
simply the case that even if you um use
very respected material that has been
checked for quite quite a while for
years often books like by D retki and
whatever um it's very often the case
that students of all levels they find
other ideas and very often they're
interesting so um it's U it's it's very
rewarding um being a being a
teacher okay playing Yak Jacob OS jaob
Bost let's
see yeah Kings Indian Kings indan is
always entertaining with both sides
you're
right let's go for a sicilian I got a
request for a sicilian so I might as
well go for it with this move
order yeah you can challenge me I don't
mind
that I'm not sure if I'm open for
challenges but let's just try I mean if
uh if I'm somehow um not open to
challenges just uh give me
um give me an information yeah yeah you
can just challenge me I will not start a
new game in the pool after that and try
to challenge
me and well this guy is playing the Tano
Sicilian and his I mean really Knight C8
and S isn't this a bit
slow that looks very
slow I'm just playing this caveman style
and push everything towards his uh his
King very often caveman style is not bad
in the
cilian B6 B5 Knight B6 yeah that's all
nice but it takes
ages huh
okay let's see I will just push as
mentioned
my experience in the open cilian is very
limited but I know that white usually
goes for the throat
so against D4 nimso and Boo or King's
Indian defense um it's both good of
course the the king's Indian um is a is
a sharper and strategically more risky
opening while the nimzo is is obviously
very sound and um and very reliable so
um it's simply a different different
animal both
openings
um I don't want to take on A4 much an
interesting move maybe I should just go
back yeah hi Oliver it's cool if you
watch this
stream yeah I went with this bishop d2
move it was kind of of irritating Knight
A4 interesting Try by
like King B1 a little bit of a lazy move
I know but um let's get this in first
and and then I'm going for G6 here next
move come
on or Bishop D3 maybe just Bishop D3
first but I don't know sometimes Bishop
H3 is good undermining this
E6 is it allowed to have some wine
during a feeda tournament H um it
depends on the tournament I
guess uh I think it depends on the
tournament there are maybe some
tournaments in France where they wear
wine is simply part of the culture so
they probably don't mind that much but
it's usually not allowed to drink
alcohol um during serious
games
when is it too late to start thinking of
becoming an IM or GM H it depends a
little bit um it will get more difficult
with time but you everybody still has
room for improvement um there is there
are some limits that's that's clear
everything else would be telling lies
but um it's still possible to improve
even um when you're somewhat older okay
well this is getting serious now this
guy is putting all kinds of pieces near
my king if I take on A4 that doesn't
look
good or maybe Queen G4
is attacking E6 but maybe he can really
just take on C3
anyway that was a simple move yeah Rook
E8 and yet it was strong maybe E5 yes ah
come on I have to I have to strike here
whatever the cost I know H1 is hanging
but
okay if he takes H1 I will take
F6 so this is probably not a bad idea if
he takes
D5
maybe yeah I can recapture and then Rook
F1 stuff like
that looks kind of
fishy
um
yeah that's an IC
stream so he took took the bishop okay
I'm going to take here it is a bit
surprising isn't this quite nice now I
can actually take H1
here yeah IC asked me to uh to do this
stream some weeks ago they liked my um
my my video work so
um do I think a human could ever
dominate a top level chess computer no
that time is over but I think um that if
I mean this is not really something that
I would like to see but if a super top
player like like Carlson would play um
let's say houdin or stockfish he would
definitely score quite a serious number
of draws I'm pretty sure about that but
it would be almost impossible to get any
wins in against the comp the computer is
just defending so well that um it is um
almost impossible to
win so um how do I get this now
played he's got lots of stuff on on C3
yeah that's in fact not that easy can
take a number of times there
huh H I
need that's not easy we'll take a number
of times then the queen is on
C3 huh how do
I how do I play
this
um this looks weird but I want to get
the bishop on D3 yeah there it is simply
covering C2 so I hope that this is a
decent
idea yeah just to be safe and then I try
to attack with Rook G1 and H6 his King
is simply um is is still um is still
under
Fire it's it's a loose piece on on F7
not not easily easily
protected so A4 is
coming I can go H6 or Rook
G1 I wonder
that's not threatening that
much yeah let's still do
it with H6 coming A4
H6 maybe he has Rook um Rook
G8 h
yes Rook G8 maybe I've got Queen H5
though yeah that's okay probably Queen
H5 or not let let me check this first H
I can also
take if I move the Knight to C1 he has
A3 which is kind of a
shame not easy at
all I can also after Rook G6 Bishop F5
is also a move takes EF Queen
[Music]
F5
tough tough this
position I take now he's got Rook G1
coming wow he defended this quite
well
I don't really see how to break through
here it looks very
difficult he can secure the king here on
D7 maybe no wait King D7 I have Bishop
takes B5 check I can just take what
check
here and this is
good so now he's not attacking C2 any
anymore I can even think about the check
here or just go back but the Rook is
hanging H okay wow 19
seconds okay let's let's just let's just
check
here um giving checks
here can he go to C4 even that's sick
that's really sick
stuff um wow okay I um I won this um
someone challenged me to a game here and
I will take this challenge but um um
let's let's have let's have a look I
look at the at some
questions
um which opening would you recommend if
you want to base your play mainly on
general principles hm um depends on the
color a little bit it's um there are
some setup openings where you basically
go for a similar setup all the time like
with white like C4 G3 or the London
system or some some um Queens um Queen
Pawn openings you're limiting yourself a
little bit if you go for those uh
openings but it can be it can be a good
a good choice sometimes I will play this
challenge game because
someone challenged me so I'm going going
for that I'm declining this Gambit
here um and just go for for development
keeping it simple I will um look at some
some more questions
soon uh why did I quit poker yeah mostly
because um for the first time ever I
lost um really substantial ELO rating I
had a really bad um run in my in my leak
games and I felt like I should decide
between playing decent chess and decent
poker and um chess one
so it's um it was
interesting I still like the game game
poker is an interesting game to play and
it can at times uh even be helpful for
your chess I
think can there's a question can you
call the Arbiter if your opponent is
smelling bad on the board yes you
can this is um this is um handled under
feeder rule about distracting the
opponent okay let's see here um a nice
position that I have with a great knight
on C4 I'm going for an end game with
this queen trade he has a hard time to
avoid it yeah I can even go Queen F5 I
just want to trade the queens and play a
good play a good end
game um did you win money by playing
poker
um I yeah not really it was probably
um probably um about
even um my rating is 2556 no this was a
channel challenge game this is a
different rating pool as someone
mentioned yeah many chess players play
poker play poker it was quite funny I
was watching a poker video some weeks
ago and there was even Jennifer Shahara
playing it's quite
funny uh
why isn't the B gamit played so much in
top level chess is it because of the
king walk variation um the BOK Gambit
main line was 12 A4 for the experts is
just bad for black I
think white has um a pretty substantial
Advantage not as much Advantage as I
have in this position here but it's very
close actually I could have played
Knight A5 to 6 C6 winning the bishop but
I still can do it next
move uh no I well I installed World of
Warcraft once but I quickly discarded
it didn't really um get it let's
say yeah Knight takes C6 will come and
the bishop on d8 is just so badly placed
it will be lost quite
funny
um I got a another challenge I mean I
don't mind playing um um challenges but
he should be in the chat this is uh
important to me
um okay well he he he messaged me um he
messaged me uh in on the
IC I know he jent another match I would
have accepted actually um do you like
listening to music while playing chess
well well I I can't listen to music
while playing chess because I do the
recordings all the
time it's I cannot have music in the
background even if I want it because of
um YouTube
copyright I I I I used to listen to
music while playing but I cannot do this
anymore um yeah the lines here this um
um Leah uncore tww mentions this line
ban versus Carson and kna and
subsequence round
in the banko that's exactly the line
that I'm referring to which is a problem
for black okay I took this challenge
here okay this guy is heavily outr but
still yeah if you um want to challenge
me out of the chat just um just put out
a challenge I'm going to take some of
those
games let's see what we got here Eddie
Barber
how about teron nuclear war yeah you you
watched war games right the classic80s
movies 8s movie it's it's a good movie I
think always fun to
watch okay we got a Clos um closed
ruy let's
see yeah well I promise not to to play
my variation again with Knight C6 so I
don't do
it this is a better line than the line
that I played I recently um played
um played the
game in the in the Dutch league and
where I lost badly in the in the royz
and this was the the death nail for my
line um
um what's your favorite movie by the way
I don't know if I have one favorite
movie but I can tell you that my first
handle actually on the IC was the dude
and um I really love the big leowski
so it's uh certainly one of my favorite
movies it's just just so much fun to
watch
so this looks like a very normal
position out of the closed closed R
white has played this um yeah just just
fine let's see yeah well Knight C5 I
guess this Knight should
play big difference to the line that I
normally play is that um the C file is
open the footfall shapes speaker is odd
yeah it's funny
yeah uh I don't smoke weed
no I don't I don't smoke at all
anything
anymore okay so he gave me the bishop
pair that's good news I always love to
have the bishop
pair so I'm going to okay I'm going to
prevent any before stuff so so that I
can double on the
cile Knight H2 he wants to go with
Knight F5 it seems but I really don't
mind here there open C file must be
worth something and my Bishop on E7 it
doesn't look great but it might find a
good home on
B6 or on G5 and now going to go
G6 preventing Knight G5 and I have
Bishop to G5 where it is all of a sudden
quite nicely placed oh that's a good
position for
black I don't play an
instrument yeah this Kenny Rogers song
is from the soundtrack yes someone
mentioned this song from the big Le
Bowski it's really a cool soundtrack I
think Hotel California by the
Eagles or John to turo
bowling you don't beep with Jesus great
stuff you're entering a world of pain
yeah I hope someone understands what I'm
what I'm saying here okay what is Eddie
Barber doing in this position here he's
giving me the C file and I have
something to attack the G4 Pawn not easy
though at the
moment um do you think that consummation
of alcohol can affect your chess long
term yep I'm pretty sure about that I'm
pretty sure I'm not a huge fan of of
drugs really I mean I don't people
should do whatever they want but really
um it's it's it's not not my my stuff
really I don't I don't
um like to um I mean I drink U I drink a
beer sometimes but uh nothing nothing
serious so what am I going to do here
well B4 I guess yeah come on let's open
up the queen side that should be should
be good oh and now he's weakening
himself that's a move that I love to see
really oky doie how to do that Queen B6
or yeah probably let's let's just take
first and queen Rook C3 would be good to
get in yeah Rook A3 Rook C1 yeah the
thing f four really weakens the whole
position and now I'm threatening also um
um Bishop takes F4 and Rook takes
D3 um wow just went
back yeah I think E5 yeah is the best
Square on the whole board so I'm going
for that if he takes D6 I give the check
and take
D3 did you ever use your chess skills in
real life um I think that um um chess
skills they have some relevance um in in
real life um if you are used to playing
a tournament chess it helps you in
keeping the concentration level high
this is really something that um you
will be better better in than than most
uh I say regular people and it um helps
you with one thing decision making
normally because in chess you're used to
making decision in limited time and um
this is something that you need to do in
many jobs for example I'm totally sure
that strong chess players would be um
excellent Traders on the stock market or
or options Traders or stuff like that
simply because uh this is the same skill
set and um there have been some uh some
cases where I mean um Luke mcshain of
course Works in in banking in London for
Goldman Sachs and he's I think in
Trader if I'm not totally wrong there
but it is a it is a comparable skill
set okay he wants to go Knight G5 is
there some
way
to make sure nothing bad is happening to
me maybe F6 yeah come on F6
this this bishop on E5 is like the best
piece ever ever ever so just
great um how do I do that Rook Rook
f8 yeah I don't know is he threatening
something
here maybe threatening to take F6 I
don't want to take H3 this is not
looking so
great after Queen takes he has Queen E6
that's not not good
but I can play this move that's
good I been look at some some questions
after the
game and try to answer them to the best
of my
abilities going to take this and F7 I
thought King G7 should do the trick I SP
spend a moment to work that out and I
hope I worked it
out
correctly and I think that's it yeah I
has this check but I can take and then
take on
D1 it should win I hope hope I'm not
blundering
stupidly yeah he lost on time but
um it um um Le in who are you what's
your handle I don't let let me before I
accept that challenge I want to look at
um some of the
questions um let's have a look it's
difficult to get all the
questions
answered um do I sing in the shower no I
don't well this kind of questions are
funny
um what percentage of your calculation
do you say loud and Live Blitz Games
that's hard to
tell I mean if we look at my games you
see that I'm not a very calculation
heavy player so
um but of course um I'm not saying um
saying all the all the lines it's simply
not possible you do much of it like
subconsciously okay I accepted a
challenge
here I accepted um a challenge here from
from the chat so let's see we got a
nimzo and I'm going to play my line here
with Knight
C6 are you religious no not
really not
really okay I'm going with E5 five
that's
the that's the idea why is 960 not more
popular among um strong
players um I don't know
really
um I like to play
it I like to play it but uh it is
difficult to even get games
yeah can you recommend a book uh for
someone around 1200 to understand Texas
but is looking to improve in other areas
um I can tell you what I use a lot in my
my training sessions I like the book
series by Art to
usov um this a series of books that I
think is really good just look for you
supp
yeah yeah it's
um it's a number of um books it's book
serious yeah B4 is not really great it
gives me great squares for my
pieces I will play some more 5 minute
pool after that but I want to give the
what I give the want to give the
um challeng this a
chance um what is my opinion of King's
Crusher yeah Trion is a friend of mine
he helped me a lot when I started with
YouTube We also met in London he's a
he's a nice guy and he's actually um and
this is not um this is not U something
that I say because we are we have um
yeah I mean the buildup and boost
evolution series uh that's not um
because we're friends um only but I
think he's really a talent and chess
player he's
um actually I think if he would would
really work on his chess he could
improve considerably he's um playing um
lots of stuff by ear and some of his
open openings are really really not that
great and uh yeah I mean he has
potential for for being a really strong
player
um
[Music]
um I'm not going to play on chess Cube
yeah well I play on chess Cube sometimes
but the problem is simply I mean those
tournaments it is technically not good
what happens there I had this terrible
leg issue when I last tried it and
sometimes really very there are not many
um many uh players around it's simply
not a really great
server there are interesting things here
and there but it's uh it's difficult
really to to get some reliable
games um I rarely play uh Play Kings
Crusher really we did some of those dual
commentary games and uh well I had a
huge plus score but this is I think kind
of normal given given the the the
difference in in playing
strength but he's very much dependent on
the position that he gets give him a
good attacking position and he's really
really dangerous he's a very dangerous
player that's that's totally clear if I
get if do something stupid he will
definitely crush
me Okie doie yeah I want to activate
here Rook on A3 he's got slightly off
the pieces are somewhat off The Rook on
F4 is a strange
piece and uh sometimes I have ideas with
queen E5 so it looks quite quite
active
um
did you ever play uh Jerry from chess
Network um um I'm not totally sure I
mean well the answer is yes but I uh I
know that I played him a couple of times
on IC because someone uh mentioned that
to me he knows his handle on ICC and uh
but I don't know the name and I don't
know the score yeah
um do I get financial compensation from
IC or using their logo for free um I'm
not using I don't know I don't get your
point I you mean why I put the logos on
my um on my
um um well I put the logos on on this um
new layout thing that I tried it was
mostly to fill the space it was not a
paid
thing um how many hours a day you devote
to chess what are your other Hobbies so
well um well I'm I'm doing chess
professionally so it's uh it's quite a
lot it's quite a
lot we are talking about 8 to 10 hours
or more it's really a lot it's really a
full-time
job C1 F4 I'm going to win material now
that's that's quite nice yeah
um it is football shaped yes it is
actually Zeppelin shaped it's called the
Zeppelin the speaker system in the in
the
video um do I think engines are
destroying chess H that's the wrong
wrong way to put it um they are um very
helpful in certain areas but they are
not um not really helpful in in others
um especially I have to I'm doing a
couple of couple of more five minute um
games um in the pool it is there
especially um um
problematic um when it comes to um to
watching games
online it is um simply um simply a case
oh I get a good challenge here from a
decently R player and uh he chatted with
me earlier so I'm going to take this
channel this will be a good game um um
it is it is um a problem when uh people
nowadays watch um high level chess and
they watch um those broadcasts with an
engine on and the engine will tell them
all kinds of things yeah like this move
was now uh I don't know getting the
valuation from 0.5 5 to 0.7 and whatnot
and then they claim wow this was a
mistake and why is I don't know Cs and
playing that badly and so on and this is
just terrible because uh they they have
no appreciation how good those top human
players are actually playing the level
of play is absolutely fantastic and um
of course they are not hitting the the
top engine moves all the time but it's
just terrible to see really weak players
who have no understanding whatsoever um
sometimes um yeah yeah claiming uh
things online just because they can read
out an evaluation of the engine it's
really um really a bad um development on
the other hand it's of course excellent
that there are those broadcasts but I
think it's a good idea for the broadcast
to use the engines very very
selectively
uh I am an E5 player and I think Ban's
book is Far Below in term of quality
When comparing with gustafson's DVD
don't don't I think so no I don't think
that at
all um I mean gustafson's DVD is really
nice and I used it extensively but I
don't see any problem with Ban's
book and uh it's also a matter of
selection Gustaf son in his DVD this is
a big difference he CH very good lines
but he didn't um allow much of um a
choice yeah it's mostly just one line uh
in each opening and that's it and what
ban does and what what I really like
about the book is that um he actually
gives you some choices yeah like um the
two knights against the um the the
Italian and so on that that's really
nice um
what is your favorite chess commentator
um I like I like quite um quite some I I
like yasa seran he's very really nice
and also a nice guy and um of course I
also like Peter Sidler for she knowledge
yeah just just so great to have a um um
yeah a world class player doing
commentary it's um it's just
excellent um ok Oki this is a
complicated position here um what am I
doing now he went
C5 I can go A3 takes
there not sure about it
all Danny kin is also also
good do you consider engines like
stockfish like a sort of free GM
coaching yeah well if you show me an
engine that um Can Explain ideas to you
or why a specific move is better than um
than another move then uh well then my
job is basically gone I'm I'm a I'm a
chess teacher and I can actually explain
to you why some evaluations are like
they are and um it is um not really
helping to just read out an evaluation
yeah the the engine is very helpful in
concrete positions so um it is a useful
tool but it cannot replace um someone
who actually can can explain what's
happening the whole the whole big
picture let's
say
um no it doesn't cost me chess never
costs me sleep after loss oh black just
blundered a piece here D7 he just he
just just gave me the
D7 D7
Bishop uh do you know Ben fold yeah well
I know him I know his uh his videos and
stuff but I don't know him personally I
think they um they they're entertaining
he's an entertaining
commentator how did you analyze in days
without engine yeah H your
head yeah well of course you made
mistake
make mistakes but
um it happens yeah you make mistakes all
the
time
um yeah we we didn't have engines back
then we have to think uh and do the
commentary for
ourselves you know it's sometimes very
interesting um to look at all the uh all
the all the commentaries yeah like game
collections that were were done by some
great players and to check how good the
annotations are compared to modern day
uh computer um supported annotations and
you will find some annotations of
classic games by great players they were
fantastic really fantastic I recently um
um some weeks ago recently as maybe a
little bit wrong but uh I I I did a
video on on the game lson with white
against pan Santa Monica
1966 um some people might know the game
I did it in my in my uh chess Giants
series and I looked at this um
game with uh with Len's notes and Len's
annotations were fantastic absolutely
fantastic he uh basically made no
serious mistake one or two slide things
but uh this was fantastic level
absolutely fantastic level did you ever
ever watched the BBC's The Master game
yes I did and the master game uh was the
inspiration for my
channel yeah um a friend of mine asked
me uh to to to do this kind of video
this blitz video with commentary and uh
he mentioned the master game
so do I have female students no I don't
have any it's um yeah statistically
probably a normal thing but uh
unfortunately no one it's um it's really
a shame that we have um this kind of
lopsided distribution between male and
female um Queen E8 yeah come on let's
trade the Queens what's the highr rated
player that you have beaten over the
board yeah that's uh easy I beat uh
Grand Master mik
gurovich at the time um he he's probably
not so well known nowadays he's mostly a
coach nowadays for the Turkish Chess
Federation um gurovich at the time was
rated
2,600 his highest rating was um he was
number five in the world at one point um
but I have to admit that um I have to
admit that in that game I had the
distinct feeling that he had some some
extra watka or something the day before
the game I mean I was really satisfied
with how I played it was it was nice but
uh I think I think he wasn't in top
shape in this
game um okay I'm going to play yet
another five minute pool
game um Do You Believe chess should
remain separated by gender well there is
a there is no there are just separate um
woman
tournaments I don't know I'm not a huge
fan of that not a huge fan but I mean
okay they can do it it's it's it really
doesn't matter to me um though so much I
mean what I definitely think that uh
what doesn't make so much sense is to
have the separate female titles I I
don't really get that one I mean wgm is
just um a little bit easier to get than
the the general I am title so if they
have the strength they should just put a
little bit more in and get the I am
title and uh well W
wfm I don't know I mean it's those
titles are a little bit outdated in
general anyway so uh I mean the general
titles are also think I think a little
bit outdated and uh I don't really see
why you should have separate female
titles but I mean it's not something
that I discuss which with
um which um with with much um I don't
know yeah enthusiasm it's I don't really
care that much what do you think about
doping and chess
um well I don't I don't really know
about doping in terms of um like um
drugs yeah uh I don't I don't really
think that this
um this would work but I'm not an expert
I really have no idea I think there are
drugs that people people take for um for
um for studying and stuff like that so I
don't really know I don't really know if
um if this there's something but they
definitely should U should uh make sure
that the computer cheating is uh is U is
taken care of this is a huge danger to
huge danger to um to professional
competitive
chess uh do I enjoy watching super GM
tournaments in person yeah I do I love
to go to the London candidates
um um since you move from C5 to E5 does
it mean that you think C5 is inferior no
absolutely not
um I mean you can play um lots of
openings really the the main point is
that you should know what you're
doing and uh and like the position time
and this is the main point not um if
some super GM or what whatever um is
playing
it C5 E5 it's all okay you just need to
know what you're
doing okay
um yeah why do people cheat in chess
yeah it's a different a difficult thing
to answer I don't really um I don't
really uh I don't really
know are there any any popular chess
players you
dislike
well yeah I don't really want to answer
that everybody has their their
preferences I can tell you who I like I
mean I really like uh I mean from the
kind of things that uh that he says and
how he handles himself I like aonian a
lot would there be a woman world
champion in your life lifetime
H difficult I really don't um it's not
very likely but
uh just a matter of Statistics yeah
there are not so many wom playing women
players and um this this this makes this
whole thing difficult Okie doie he's um
he put his Knight on C6 in an
unprotected state so I wonder if I have
a move like Knight G5 here maybe Knight
G5 Knight A5 I have Queen A4
check do you think they should add a
title above GM I don't know if this um
leads to to
anywhere yeah he played Knight A5 so I'm
going to give this
chick and King E7 that does not look
right it really does not look
right but how do I punish it yeah Knight
E4
maybe or is there
something n that's good KN
E4
[Music]
um many
questions did you study economics and no
I
didn't um I actually it's hard to I
don't have a degree No I um I just did
um I I just learned on the job let's say
it's
um I don't know how to explain it to
someone U yeah in Germany you can just
learn on the job it's a two two twoyear
process at a bank in my case it was a
bank yeah
um okie dokie where to go Queen B4 I
guess or queen H4 I could go to H4 yeah
this is maybe not bad getting a Tempo
what I want is I want to play D4 and
open up the position yeah come on that
must be right yeah I cannot believe this
is not right opening up the position
here against the king the king is on
E7 so oh wow okay my queen is not having
many
squares have to go
here it still must be right I'm I'm I'm
pretty confident about
that okay for rookie one check yeah an
apprenticeship exactly yeah I did an
apprenticeship in a
way night
D5 Knight D5 check looks good and then
Bishop e
three Queen A4 B5 I just
take I
think as a German what is your opinion
on German nationalism H wow that's a
difficult question not really not really
um um not really chess
related um
yeah I'm uh more of a liberal um in a
political sense and um well what I do
think is that um I don't think that um
the let's say right-wing national
movement in Germany is is any much
different than in in some other European
countries um for example in France um
foreign National is much much bigger
let's say and has gotten much more votes
um I think the actual really right-wing
people in Germany they relatively um
this is a relatively small part of the
of the
community um wow this is a terrible
position for black The Rook on D1 the
Knight on
D5 how much do I like pizza yeah I love
pizza but I don't eat it try to get um
more physically fit yeah black black
resigned yeah this is just just too much
I've got all piece in the attack for
just uh for just one
Pawn okay this stream is already on 73
minutes and uh it's supposed to be 1
hour so it was a a good chat I hope you
in um enjoyed it um if you could give 10
years away from your life to became
chess champion would would you accept it
h that's uh
complicated um I live in northr West
faia
um which gambits do you play in real
life play um
probably probably no real gambits in
your sense the Queen's
Gambit okay so I have to have to quit
now guys I'm I'm on
75 minutes around that I hope you
enjoyed this stream um I wish all of you
a Merry Christmas which U right um right
around the corner yeah if you want
longer streams than 1 hour you should uh
yeah ride IC I don't mind to do a little
bit more but um one hour is one hour
that's how we I didn't play the modern
okay well guys next time Merry Christmas
and I'll be back next week I guess so uh
we will do something um after Christmas
and before the
um um before the new year and one
question here have you played with
Magnus Carlson yeah when he was a 10year
old on IC okay thanks a lot guys that's
it
bye